[音楽]
皆さんこんにちは植物使った空間デザインやってますめざと言います
決して体育の先生ではありません
これ
耳澄ましてもらっていいですか
そうこれをとなるやつではないのでちょっとテーブルの上に置いておきます普通の花
です
今日は皆さんお越しいただいてありがとうございますそしてこの素敵な会場ご用意ただ
てと皆さんありがとうございます
今日ですね皆さん何の日かご存知ですか
何の日ですか今日が
をゴールデンウィークほかいませんか
平成最後の土曜日いろいろありますね今日はですね
実は私8回目の結婚記念日でしてそんな日にですねお呼びいただいて本当にうれしいな
と思っているわけです
まあよくはこの辺までにして私が何をやってるかちょっとお話ししたいと思います
植物使った空間デザインをやっているんですけどもうちょっと事例を
ご覧いただきたいなと思っていますこちらの
スライドなんですけれども来年東京オリンピックあります我々ですね東京オリンピック
のマラソンを起こすのデザインを担当しております
これ奥に雷もがあるんですけどもそこに伝統工芸出かけの際いくのですねシチューを
作って
区の花で台東区の区の判断は朝がを満開にするというプロジェクトをこの
やってますこの満開にするランダーが通過する瞬間
6時にスタートするっていうのが決まったので6時40分から45分くらいに何な通過
するんですけども
ここにですね花を咲かせるとでこの花を育てているのが地元の小学生です
そんなプロジェクトをやっていますもう一つ
こちらがですね表参道にあるマートランとあるコーヒーショップなんですけども
このようにですね緑を使ったりあとちょっと右側にですね
水滴が上から落ちてくる掃除なんですけれどもこれは天気と連動して水滴の量が変わっ
たりですね
自然や環境との調和を促すようなそんなデザインを行っています
で我々これをやる時とっても大切にしている未来があります実はですね使っている土
全部人間が出した
海から使ってます我々植物を増やすために何かこう地球を傷つけて人間のために緑を
増やすってとても
エコシステムではないなぁと思っているので人間が出した月を土
人間が出したゴミを再利用して土に活かしているとそんな取り組みを行っています
ちょっと本来の方に戻ります
地球に
生物が生まれて地上に
生物が登場して海の中からだいたい5億年ぐらいかかると言わ言われています
我々人類どのくらいかというと700万年くらいですね
で今日テクノロジーの話いっぱいありましたけど
インターネット発明されて50年
ですよそのくらいのスケール感でちょっと今日のお話聞いていただきたいなと思ってい
ます
3つ
私人生の価値観が変わった出来事があります
一つは20年前ちょっと病気を患ってですね
死を意識したことですあ
死ぬんだって本当に思ったことがあります
二つ目その真逆
私には男の子の2人子どもがいるんですけども
子供が産まれた瞬間性命を感じたこと
ここでも価値観が大きく変わりました
この子たちの未来を良くしたいなぁとそういうスイッチが入りました
3つ目これが今日主にお話することなんですけどもアフリカの大地を踏んだことです
人類が生まれたホモサピエンス誕生の地といわれる
ケニアのサバンナの真ん中に降り立ちました
ここを観ていただいた通りこのセスナ機でですね
タラップが開いた瞬間にこの土の滑走路の上に一歩踏み出したんですよ
したら土の匂い風の薫
太陽の熱全身で感じたんですよほんとね冗談じゃなくこの
体内の dna がさわざわざ
したんですよで自分自身がわぁ生き物だって感じた瞬間です
でそのとき何を思ったかというと
この感覚自分で生き物なんだなっていう子の dna がざわつく感覚を全人類が持っ
てたら戦争がなくなるなあと思ったんですよ
そう思って立ち上げた作ったのが植物を使った空間デザインの事業部になります
我々のチーム今総勢は50人
ちょっとなんですけどもまぁ事例を見せしたような植物を使った空間デザインを行って
います
もう一つ
これ空港なんですよ
この土の滑走路の空港にですねあれ掘っ立て小屋待合所ですからね
来るか来ないか分からないと飛行機も明日来るらしいよって言われるんですよ
で行って見て来ないんですよあれじゃあ下にしようかってそんな感じなんですけども
この土のパスとローの隣でライオンが出てたりとか
像が歩いてたりとかキリンが歩いてたりとかそんなところの経験をしました
それが私の原点ですちょっとここからは2つ
価格の事例をお話ししたいと思います
一つ目は人の科学です
皆さん性格ってだいたい自分の性格って5歳までに決まるってご存知ですか
基本的な性格は今5歳までに決まると言われています
でですね私たち植物使った空間設計のチーム50人くらいいるってお話ししたんです
けれども
スタッフ9人全員にですね世界中のビッグデータと産業心理學院のデータを掛け合わせ
た
アセスメントを受けさせていて生活
魚定理を評価しているんですよその数値によって
プロジェクト組んだりとか人事移動したりとかそんなことをやっています
私自身どんな性格かと言いますと独立心が強い
革新性が高い日本人にはほとんどないんですけども決断力が非常に高いと言う
そんな資質を持っていますじゃ逆に僕の弱いところは何かというと
細部への配慮が足りないあと思いやりが一番低かったですね
ね50人もマネージャー50人のマネージャーなんですけどそんなマネージャーはどう
なのかなというのはちょっと後で呼ぶかが来てるんで聞いてみてください
で性格の診断をして一つ疑問だったんですよ
人間ってその後歳までに決まる環境で性格が決まるのかそれとも遺伝的に
せいか
が形成されるのかちょっと自分自身気になったので自分のゲノム解析をやりました
360項目くらい全部自分自身どんな
遺伝子を持ってこのように生まれてきたのかなと
全部話とちょっと長くなっちゃうので面白かった
自分のルーツの話をチョップしたいと思います
男性に引き継がれると言われている y 染色体というものを紐解いていくと自分の
ルーツがわかるんですね
でその y 染色体によると様は父方ですね
父方の生殖体によると4万年前から東アジア者にずっと定住してたあああんっ
的な民族日本人の55%ぐらいを持っている遺伝子を父方の方は持っていました
今度母が他の方これは女性に引き継がれるミトコンドリア dna というがあるん
ですけども
ミトコンドリアゲノムを見ていくと母端の方は4万年前に東南アジアから海
にを渡って日本列島を開拓したそんな
ゲノムを持っている血が流れていましたでなんか現代でそれを築けることないかなーと
思って色々思い返したんですね
って人とありましたお正月とかお盆休みとか実家に帰ったりするじゃないですか
で当然両方の家にお邪魔してですね挨拶しに行くんですけども
父方の方いつ行っても同じ銘柄のビールなんですよそりゃ4万年前から東アジアに安定
的にいるようなそう
いう精神を持っていますからね方や母が他の方
母が他の方の宴会の席には毎回新商品のビールが並ぶんですよ
うわぁこれ遺伝子かなって全然科学的根拠はないんですけれどもそんな経験がありまし
た
で
二つ目ちょっと温度は
緑や自然の方の科学のお話をしたいと思うんですけども
ちょっと皆さんに聞きたいことがあります
この写真
人生思い起こしてもらって
ふと海が見たくなるそんな思いに駆られたことがある人てあげてもらえますか
海みたいな方は結構いらっしゃいますねこれはどうですか
ふと山に行きたくなるあーなんか森の中で深呼吸したいなぁとそんな気分になったこと
ある人てあげてください
結構いらっしゃいますねじゃあもっと日常に落としてこれどうですか
お花一輪もらってすごく癒されたりほっこりした気持ちになったりとか
道端に咲いてるお花匂いを嗅いでみたりとか
それで心が豊かになった経験がある人てあげていただけますか
結構いますねじゃあなぜこんなにみんなお金が大好きな世の中で
人は自然を求めるんですか
別に山に行ってもお金儲けられるわけでもないし全く不経済の状況だと思うんですけど
なんで人は自然を欲するんですか
疲れたら海に行きたくなりますか疲れたら山みたくなりますか
なんでだと思いますか決して合理的な恋じゃないですよね
お金払ってキャンプイクって何のために山の中に行くんですが山の中いくためにお金
稼いでるみたいな
すごく変な
サイクル今なってますねなんで人は自然を求めると思いますか
私がケニアに行った時の体験と非常に近しいんですけども
そのキーワードなる言葉それがバイオフィリアという言葉ですこのバイオフィリアと
いう言葉まぁ簡単に言うとですね
人類ホモサピエンスが進化の過程で
先天的に
生き物とか命のある物っていうものに興味を引くっていう本能的な欲求があるという
ものです
このバイオフィリアの特徴的なものが見ただけでそれは生命のあるものか
命のないものかっていう判別する能力が人間にはあるというふうに言われています
どっちを
飲むかというと当然命のある方を好むんですよ
お花にしろ植物にしろ動物にしろ
それをバイオフィリアという表現で表しています
でこれはもともと50年前ですね
ドイツの社会心理学者エーリヒフロムがですね開くについてっていう本を書いているん
ですね
人間にとっての悪とは何かとその中で
ネクロフィリアという模様はしたいあい
死体を好む傾向のある人も少数いるんですよ人間の中にもその
対義語としてバイオフィリア生命愛という表現をしてます
でそれをかいつまんで紹介したのがアメリカの社会生物学者の良いようウイルソンさ
ですね
彼がバイオフィリアという本を出してですね世界的に
にその潮流が広がりました
近年ですねこのバイオフィリアの心理的傾向を模したデザイン手法をバイオフィリップ
デザインといいます
このバイオ felix デザインというのは簡単に言うと人と自然が調和した時に
健康とか充実とと充実度とかそういったものが上がっていくデザイン手法と例えば
4前項の近くでは生産性が上がりますよとか
当然太陽光の当たらないところよりも
当たったところのほうが気持ちいいじゃないですかそういった方が幸せだと彼は上がり
ますよとそういったことを表しています
で有名なバイオフィリックデザインの提唱者
建築家まぁちょっと建築に限ってたら知っていると思いますけれども
フランクロイドライトは有名なバイオ fick デザインの提唱者です
彼のデザインで川の中に建物を作ったりとかおりと一体化するようなデザインをしたり
とかそういったか
と見たことあると思うんですけれどもそういったデザインが今すごく主流になって注目
を浴びています
で
植物で
今までですね最新の科学で表すと今までは植物花とか緑を見たときに
ストレスの高い人が
リラックスあ
していくものだと誰もみなさんを持ってると思うぞ
花見ると癒されるとか緑につつまれると気持ちいいとかリラックスするとか
最新の科学をそうじゃないんですよ千葉大学の宮崎先生というぐらいのフェローが世界
的にも有名な先生がいるんですけども
誰が泰明した価格によると植物っていうのは高い
トレス状態にある人は当然落ち着きますよと逆にリラックスしすぎている1秒はうつ
状態の人とかやる気のない人っていうのは興奮させてくれますよとでこの真ん中辺の
ゾーンに落ち着かせてくれる
ここは何かといったら様は人間らしさあるべき人間らしさの
ところに調律してくれる作用があるというものを発表して大いに話題になりました
今年もう一つですね衝撃的な論文が発表されたんですけども
デンマークのオーフス大学こんな発表しましたこれは94万人の子供を調査した結果
です
ああああああ
自然に囲まれて育った子の方が55%
精神疾患にかかり難いというものを科学で解明してます
どうですか植物見てリラックスする
自然に囲まれた方が精神的にも安定する
当たり前じゃないですか
そう思いません
でも科学で証明されるとより納得感はしません
だか皆さんね今現在頭でっかちになり過ぎているんですよね
もっと身体の内面から感覚的にいいなと思ったものをより素直に自分の内面と向き合っ
ていいと認める必要があるんじゃないかなと思っています
で皆さんが感じる
5ないですなんかいっていうのはたぶん皆さんにとって良いはずですよ
気持ちがいいとかなんかこれやだなーとかそれが徐々に徐々にテクノロジーの新田で
当たり前となんかいっていうのが立証され始めています
で
今日はですね皆さんに全身でその感覚を研ぎ澄まして欲しいと思いまして
全員にお花一輪をプレゼントしますなので今日お持ち帰りいただいてこの花を見て
いただいて匂いを変えたりとか
リラックスするなぁとか自分の内面と対話してほしいんです
そのときに自分の感覚と思っちゃってほしいんですけれども
感覚って大きく4つの
分類に分けられるんですね
一つは頭で感じる特殊感覚
これは光とか色とか弟か味とかそういったものを頭で考えて感じる感覚です
で2つ目皮膚で感じる皮膚感覚
これは暑いとか寒いとか手触りとか
この2つ花でできますね
ぜひ薔薇の棘させてみてください痛いですからそれも感覚です
海で見てください香りがするかもしれません
3つ目内蔵で感じる深部感覚お腹痛くなるって言うのは別に皮膚が感じてるわけじゃ
なくて中から感じますよねそういったもので最後は体の深いところで感じるし3ボタン
書くというのが
ます今私ここでしゃべっていて例えば手を差し出します右手の親指この辺にあるなって
いうのは無意識でなんとなくわかるんですよ
これが深部感覚あとはふくらはぎ痙攣しているなぁとよくマラソンとかする人ってなん
か乳酸たまってきた
あの見えてないのになんでわかるんだという話ですけれどもそれを
深部感覚と言いますなのでみなさ
1もう全身を使って教
バラのお花プレゼントしますので感じてみてください
自分自身と向き合ってみてください
最後に
時代はいつも訂正と話す訂正をいったりきたりします
今テクノロジーの流れが体税だとしたらもしかしたら
し全海域はアンチ天井かもしれません
例えば服着るだけでは暖かくなる服着るだけで涼しくなる服いっぱいありますよね
あれが売れてくるとカウンターカルチャーのように人間の感覚が衰えるんじゃないか
もっと乾布摩擦しようとかなにかけ体を鍛えようとかそういうカルチャーが出てくるん
ですよ
そうやって時代っていうのはいつも訂正
ダウンステージをいったりきたりするんですねで必ず
中丹の良いところが落ち着く時代がきますそれを人体勢と言います我々は植物のある
生活っていうものが
人0人になるように今はもしかしてアンチ訂正でカウンターカルチャーかもしれないん
ですけれども
ここにもう1本をないじゃないですか植物
本来はあるべきだと思うんですよねある方が気持ちいいはずなんですよ
それを人体勢していくっていうのが僕たちの仕事かなと思っています
でここの真ん中のゾーンは何かって言われたらやっぱり
人間らしさのような気がしますあるべき姿
これからのビジネス
私は2つに分かれると思っています未来のビジネスが一つ目
人間が創造したことを形にしていくこと
そういう仕事例えば車を飛ばしたい
火星に住みたい
多分皆さん
もうできるようなイメージ湧きません
わきますよねそういう美人ですもう一つ大切なビジネスがあると思っています
それはそのテクノロジーを正しく使うために人間を性善説に導く仕事それが僕たちの
仕事の一つかなぁと思っていますその開発されたテクノロジーっていうのは正しく使わ
れない
と正しい未来に立っていきません
今世界的に今回の日がざらすもそうですけども
こんな風潮あるんじゃないかなと
やろうと思えば何でもできちゃうんだけど本当にそれやってしまって良いの ai
どんどん開発されるけど癖とか作られてるけどどんどん行っちゃうんじゃないどっ
その人間本来持ってるあるべき倫理観
それとの対話っていうものが非常に切迫しているんじゃないかなと思っています皆さん
どんな未来をつくりたいです
おっ
どんな進化を成し遂げたいですか
で進化という言葉も非常に定義がいっぱいあります
哲学者がいう進化ってこういうことなんですよ自分が何者かを探ること
これを哲学者が言ってます
心理学者はこう言うんですよ情報を処理し続けることが知りかだって
生物学者はこう言います世代をまたいで集団の性質が変化すること
個人が変わっても突然変なんですよ集大が時代を超えていかないと進化していかないん
ですよ
でここでとっても大切なことがあります
新田は親父ではありません=になることもありますよ
シンパと進歩がイコールじゃないっていうことを覚えておいていただきたいなと必ず
しも正しい進化をするとは限りません
どうせなら人類の未来っていうのは進歩の方に勧めたいなぁというそんな気持ちが強く
あります最後に
ダーウィンの言葉で終わりたいと思います
進化論でおなじみ台は生き残る種
代々続く生き残るシュっていうものは最も強いものでもなくて
最も知的なものでもないとそれは変だに最もよく適用した者だけが生き残るという風に
進化論の中で話
しています
今日の私のお話が皆さんの何か人生のヒントになればいいなと思っています
今日は帰って私は結婚記念日を祝いたいと思いますので皆さんも素敵なゴールデン
ウィークをお過ごしくださいありがとうございました
[拍手]